Trump had a little misstep in his speech
today he gave a speech made a little
mistake that can happen I think we
should forgive him yeah during a speech
to African leaders today he was speaking
to African leaders President Trump
accidentally made up the nation of
nambia
made up nambia he just said nambia even
worse he promised to help nambia in
their war with narnia but i will help
you with narnia and then then he talked
for half an hour but what losers they
are narnia they're losers they got a
Lion King yeah you can't be ruled by law
and President Trump is using his 2020
campaign fund to pay his legal fees
which experts say is wrong but not
illegal yeah
coincidentally wrong but not illegal is
also Trump's twenty20 campaign slogan
Attorney General Jeff Sessions is
travelling around yesterday Attorney
General Jeff Sessions visited Portland
Oregon he went to Portland yeah after
his visit sessions said you know
dreadlocks aren't so scary when they're
on a white guy
Twitter just announced it has new
controls twitter has new controls to
block people who advocate violence yeah
yeah great yeah but don't worry you can
still follow President Trump on Facebook
so come out there anyone excited about
this new iPhone 10 okay Wow so that's
the rich section Apple CEO Tim Cook is
claiming that the $1,000 iPhone 10 is a
good value that's what he said yeah Cook
said it's the last phone you'll ever
need for the next eight months so until
we come up
Arnold Arnold Schwarzenegger is gonna
return for the next Terminator movie
yeah
[Applause]
he's coming back to the next Terminator
movie and this one Arnold goes back in
time to erase all traces of him hosting
Celebrity Apprentice that's just like I
think it never happened and then I got
to mention this this is a weird when
it's come out that some species of frogs
have sex orgies sex frogs that have sex
orgies yeah yeah these are followed the
next morning by the frogs doing the hop
of shame come on free pay nothing
you